[Music]
my name is Drew bradstock I wanted to
welcome you to our session talking about
how gka and Cloud run can help
accelerate application development so I
am in charge of product for both
serverless and criminal joining me today
is staran who leads product for
serverless and we also have the pleasure
of Brian and Cor joining us from Etsy
where they're going to tell the real
story versus the Google story of what
their experiences are with containers
now it's really hard to believe that
it's been over 20 years since Google
created Borg and our own container
management system we've made huge
strides during that time period let me
go ahead hold on one second we've made
huge strides during this time period and
crias itself is over 10 years old at
this point it's hard to imagine what
people did with containers before that
that point outside of Google during this
time period we've looked at automation
we've looked at efficiency we've looked
at security such that all of you don't
have to take care of that that led us to
actually add autopilot mold where much
of the work is done by Google for you
still the flexibility of ku's ecosystem
and even before that we actually
pioneered with Cloud run which is the
easiest serverless offering in the
market which staren will be speaking
about later today as well now one of the
things that we're actually most proud of
is the fact you have Choice you're not
locked into either kubernetes or one
serverless product we have the options
of cloud run which gives you the ability
to get going with containers incredibly
quickly now containers for many people
moving from Legacy VMS or older on-prem
systems where your build systems may be
a little Legacy or long in the tooth can
be really challenging this is where we
found customers have accelerated that
Journey with Cloud run because it's Ain
without locking you into a traditional
pass and allows you to get going quickly
Additionally you can scale up to handle
any workload possible and one of the
cool things we'll walk through is how
easy it is to actually move your
containers from cloud run to GK or from
GK to Cloud run now on the flip side if
you don't want or if you do want to use
kubernetes gka is a great option for you
so Cloud run is a really fast way to get
going containers all up and we're seeing
more and more customers actually stay
with us and grow large scale deployments
like Ikea and others but for gka our
Focus has been one make sure that we
actually practice what we preach in
terms of our investment in open source
for instance in the last 60 days we've
made more contributions to kubernetes
than many of the leading Cloud vendors
have in the history of kubernetes and
this is really where chopping wood and
carrying water and doing the hard work
in EN enhancing the products based on
feedback for many of you make a
fundamental difference in terms of
implementation just being easier beyond
that if you look we have actually really
heavily optimized for new ai workloads
ai as you may have heard maybe 1 to 1500
times and that is a number this morning
has really changed the game but kinetes
is a really good fit for this but once
again one of the struggles we've seen is
that people don't want a Swiss army
knife of options they want to be able to
grow to any size but they do want a p
Nation such you can get going with gpus
or tpus or any of the leading AI
Frameworks very quickly and that's what
we're investing in our kuet right now
and lastly is autoscaling ha and
security these are all things you don't
want to have to build yourself and worry
about so we made it easy to do so now
one of the coolest things for for cloud
run is actually how easy it is to get a
container going from having that
container to live in production fully
serving traffic so we've got a nice
little demo and thankfully to Starin and
our crappy Wi-Fi across mcone so
apologies for that we've got this preset
up but Cloud run takes care of all that
heavy lifting for you it's very very
good with handling your traffic
splitting getting it fully deployed and
it literally seconds your live with
either your new iteration or a brand new
container and this has led to a lot of
companies from the smallest startups all
the way to the largest Enterprise and
digital natives embrace ing Cloud run
because of the speed to deploy and how
well it ties into all our development
tools as well as the ecosystem now Cloud
run does have two major strengths one is
traditional Services you may think about
where it's the way you really use uh
Cloud run but Cloud run jobs opens up a
huge realm of batch opportunities too
because of that great nature of zero to
1,000 and th to zero and back down so I
encourage you to check it out more and
obviously listen to staring in a few
minutes now near and dear to my heart
I've worked on GK and CRI for many years
now GK standard is the product that many
in this audience use right now one of
the cool things about it is the level of
Automation and security we've brought
into it to make it a lot simpler to
actually get your cluster going without
having to do the work you may have to do
on other clouds with this system
additionally we have looked as I
mentioned looking at gpus and tpus such
you can run any AI workloads you want
and you can play the home game of
counting how many times we mentioned AI
today but it is all a bed Simplicity
every single point of friction makes
your life more difficult so our job is
to remove the difficult bits from
kubernetes and that's where we're
constantly looking for feedback from all
of you and lastly as I mentioned is how
do we have a secure really good single
cluster environment here now one of the
problems that you still have though is
what happens if you have more than one
cluster so quick show of hands how many
of you have one one or more kues
clusters
okay how many of you have 10 or more uh
it's exercise it's four o' quick show
hands keep those hands up how many of
you have 10 or more okay how many of you
have 50 or
more okay how many of you have a hundred
or more thousand or more I was going to
say I know who's at a certain level for
all our clients but it's easy to manage
one it becomes really hard just like any
fleets like when we have VMS first come
out becomes harder and harder to manage
more and more this is also compounded by
the complexity kuet and adding all the
add-ons so what I'm really excited to
actually announce TK stole a little bit
of my thunder this morning but he's
allowed that's his job it's GK
Enterprise Edition this actually Builds
on top of GK standard still all the
functionality you have with the GK
standard right now remains with standard
edition no changes whatsoever but what
we've done is we built multi-team
multicluster management such you can
take a look at your fleets build an
observability build in security building
compliance build a config all across
many clusters at once be it a one
cluster Fleet or literally in the
thousands with some of the customers
that we're uh testing right now
additionally of security and governance
and new functionality there looking for
vulnerabilities that's all being built
to look at one cluster or many and all
part of this is actually all the
functionality we have within anthos is
now included as part of GK Enterprise
Edition so any of you using anthos for
multicloud hybrid or even on gcp all
that functionality does not go away but
is now within one unified conso and
experience within
gke what I'd like to do is actually
welcome up um the Etsy folks to walk
through their experience working with
Cloud run and a little bit of what
they've seen within GK so gentlemen I'll
leave you to introduce yourself my name
is Corey Samuels I'm the engineering
manager for Etsy service
platform um we affectionately call the
service platform ESP so you'll hear that
referred to in the presentation today um
I'm here with our Tech lead Brian Akin
and we're really excited to share a
little bit about our journey to design
and build a service platform for
Etsy we're going to walk you through the
what why and how of our platform and
then we're going to dig in to what we
built and some of the challenges and
successes that we encountered along the
way so let's start first by answering
the question why did Etsy need a service
platform so prior to moving to the cloud
in
2019 Etsy was primarily powered by a PHP
monolith that was in a Data Center and
because it was in the data center we
were constrained both technically and
hardware-wise as to what we were able to
build as the company grew the need for
services grew as well and moving to the
cloud enabled our Engineers to take
advantage of new service platforms where
they could put new Services outside of
this core monolith which still Powers
much of etsy's marketplace
today this Evolution to Services
occurred
organically but uh very quickly we saw
that some problems were emerging we saw
that teams were duplicating
infrastructure and
Scaffolding uh service attribution was
unclear sometimes ambiguous we had no
Central service catalog so Services
weren't easily visible or even
accessible and finally we had gaps in
standards operational process and
support of
services so to address these problems we
assembled a squad of Architects who
spoke to many teams around Etsy who were
writing services and ultimately the
squad created this Vision document which
would serve as the blueprint for how
service development would would uh what
what service development would look like
in in the future the core principle of
this Vision was to decouple service
writing from the infrastructure that the
services ran
on this solved two problems for us first
it freed service writers from the burden
of infrastructure and secondly it
provided us a path to introduce
standards and guard rails into the
service
architecture thanks Drew and Corey hi
I'm Brian Akin but most everyone calls
me Bacons uh slight bacon but plural uh
I'm a senior staff engineer and I've
been at Etsy since May of
2022 when I first started at Etsy uh
this Vision dock that Corey mentioned
had already been completed and then the
service platform teen and I join was
tasked with taken that vision and making
a practical working service
platform uh from that Vision document
after my initial onboarding we discussed
what would be the success criteria for a
service platform we ask oursel how can
we best spend our time and we ask oursel
often like in a year if we look back
what would be a
successful um service platform we kind
of came to the very obvious conclusion
that a successful service platform would
enhance the developer experience to make
our lives easier seems obvious right but
we needed to dig a little bit deeper
like how would we know when we were
successful you know like how would we
know when we've reached that but then
what are the actual steps we need to get
there um so to do that very quickly we
conducted interviews and did small proof
of concepts with teams around Etsy
engineering including some of the more
operational focused teams because we
want to get that perspective as well um
because we want to know what were the
day-to-day pains in both writing
services as well as supporting those
Services once they were in production
and we wanted like how could we create a
platform that would allow those writing
services to focus on
uh their business logic while providing
the operational Foundation that all
Production Services need so that we'
also uh make the lives of operators easy
as well and then finally how would this
align with this kind of architectural
Vision that came from um a little bit
from the committee there became clear
from talking with people we had two
basic use cases that which are like hey
I have a great idea how can I quickly
get that in front of custom customers by
integrated into the Etsy product and
that idea was successful how do I
support that long
term we often say on the service
platform that an engineer's time and
attention are the most valuable assets
that we have at Etsy so we want to make
sure that we made good use of our
Engineers time so we wanted to be able
to quickly iterate on the value that we
thought that the service platform could
provide knowing that the entire
engineering organization was our kind of
you know potential Marketplace for this
platform and to do that we wanted to
focus on the Etsy specific parts of a
service platform we weren't looking to
build a generic service platform for all
of the world to use but for Etsy for our
engineering organization to to use and
me being fairly new to the team I had to
rely like I say on a lot of these
interviews and talking with people and
um doing that it is a very kind of face
to-face 101 type company so the
establishing those relationships across
engineering was very important for us to
get in there and hear their story like
what was it like when you launch
something how did that go what do you
wish had gone differently about that um
so to do that we knew from the beginning
that we needed to use the highest level
service by Google or other providers
that would allow us to focus on that
Etsy specific part of the service
platform we didn't really have the time
nor the people we're a fairly small team
to make a whole lot of upfront
infrastructure decisions and
implementations before we actually dove
into the actual work of building the
service
platform while we're big fans of
offerings like gke which we've mentioned
already by using a platform like Cloud
run there were just entire classes of
problems and decisions that we just
didn't didn't have to make you know
whether we like that opinion or not it
was just something that we could start
with and sometimes just deciding takes a
lot longer than the actual doing so we
got to start off much
quicker abstraction layers are obviously
hard but we wanted to do our best to
make sure that we didn't expose too many
lowlevel details to our service
developers so that they could focus on
uh writing and supporting their business
logic so we generally don't have a
strong culture of Technology mandates
specifically in terms of platforms at
Etsy so it was very important for us to
take that into account when we were
figuring out our strategy of how we were
going to design and build this
platform we could build something that
we thought was perfect but if our
Engineers who were going to be our
future
customers weren't sold on the
platform adoption would just be
difficult and the project could fail so
our approach around this was to First
assemble a team of Engineers who had
skills both in infrastructure and
application
development after that we put three
things in place first to make sure that
we stayed aligned to that architectural
Vision that we were given we composed a
small sort of Advisory Group that
included two of the original architects
who had authored the vision and we met
with them weekly to discuss
implementation and design details of the
platform second and to ensure that we
stayed true to what our customers
actually needed we partnered with one of
our teams our ads team um because they
were already writing services and they
were a perfect fit for what what we were
planning to do so one of their Engineers
actually rotated into our team and
helped us build an MVP build and design
the MVP and then our Pilot service was
one of this team's services that they
were planning to build outside of the
platform so that aligned really really
well lastly we adopted a very flexible
and adaptable road map strategy so our
team's work on platform features and
support would align with what our
customers actually needed our our
service writing
teams so our MVP was La launched at the
end of last year and then we follow that
soon after with the launch of our ads
team pilot
in q1 of this year so now that we've
given you some historical and sort of
strategic context of our service
platform let's take a look at what we
actually
built so ESP at its
core it's a group of components that
we've glued together into a cohesive
service development experience um for
our developer interface we to write a
custom command line tool and that
integrates really really nicely with our
cicd workflow which is powered by GitHub
actions for
communication we standardized on
grpc and we use protuff for the uh
serialization
format Etsy Engineers use a pretty
broad number of languages and to help
you know get adoption going we wanted to
support as many as we were able to um so
on the service side we support go node
and Python and then on the client side
we support languages that are needed
around Etsy ecosystems like PHP Java
Scala Python and
node um so those clients are
automatically packaged up versioned and
then registered at
artifactory and then all of the services
are cataloged into our service catalog
using
backstage finally Google services
played a critical role in these
components of our platform all of our
observability tooling is powered by
Google cloud services and most
importantly all of our services are
running on cloud
run this before the launch of ESP of the
service platform each of these boxes you
see and actually the links between each
one was an a decision that a development
team had had to make the decision then
actually go and Implement that um
technology to support that and often
they would do this uh for each service
that uh they supported and since teams
are often fluid as you know this led to
you know like many many different ways
to deploy services without much
standardization as Corey had said
earlier it's so we wanted to avoid a
one- siiz fits all approach however we
did know there were key uh featur that
we needed to uh enable the general life
cycle of the services uh and support the
developers workflows and since we didn't
want to use the build it and they will
come mentality because they never come
when you build it uh we used our Pilot
service and our partner team and the ads
team to like Drive the priorities uh and
requirements for at least initial phase
of the MBP uh we wanted to make sure
that we were actually building something
that our users would actually use as
Corey said we wrote this command line
tool uh called ESP that's the primary
way in which uh developers uh interact
with the platform uh it's really a
wrapper on top of other tools as you can
probably imagine uh and it's just there
to provide a consistent kind of CLI um
interface rather than having to know you
know 10 different tools and everything
uh and it provides um common tasks for
like creating new Services as well as
working with services that are already
written if does things like it handles
your Proto uh generation so where you
generate your code uh from protoc C
files and it also handles like running
the service inside of a container
locally like you would do it in Cloud
run so that you can um have a similar
experience but it also is used to run
unit tests locally and those types of
things um it also generates uh language
specific uh container build so
developers never really have to deal
with Docker files uh and so we're able
to bake those best practices in there
particularly we're working with like our
application security team to make sure
that we get updates injected into the
platform without having to go touch you
know 10 different uh repos the service
platform also uh provides a small
framework for each supported service
language uh we call this the runner
because we are or at least I am very
terrible at naming things uh we utilize
code generation a whole lot uh sometimes
for better or
uh but what this framework does is allow
enables developers to be able to focus
on just writing like their service
methods without having to worry about
things like setting up
observability uh you know like setting
up a grpc server figuring out what port
to listen on you know like very mundane
things but these are things that if
you've never written a service if you're
starting from scratch that you have to
do there's a good bit of ceremony
involved um it also provides just a base
level of observability out of the box so
you you get pretty good you know like
metrics logging tracing and those types
of things without doing anything you
know within your service um Beyond
writing your business
logic one of the things is we wanted to
do this is this why so that a service
developer can focus on writing the code
implementing that idea like we were
talking about
earlier but having best practices for
operational and infrastructure baked
into the platform so that we provide
pretty good guard rails for most use
cases just out of the box we use the
same command line tool uh in our cicd
pipeline so the same tool that you're
running test locally that's what's
running test and cic CD for you that way
we just have some consistency uh between
the two uh hopefully this uh gets rid of
those cases where like you've always had
that flaky test in CI but it works fine
locally so that's one of the things that
we try to address I'm not going to say
we were 100% successful because you
never are but it also handles other
things like actually building the
container as we to about generating
darker images but also actually pushing
that to a container registry deploying
it to Cloud run and it automatically
handles like the uh promotion from
development to production environments
for example um we also generate what we
call batteries included clients for each
one of our supported client languages uh
so a consumer is generally working with
generated clients and not like the kind
of raw generated grpc clients if you've
ever used those but we also and we say
it's batteries included because we
include such things as service Discovery
so like if I'm working in a development
environment on service a and I need to
call service B it automatically knows
how to contact the development version
of service B without me having to tell
it um it also provides instrumentation
so automatically get all the good you
know timings and logging and setion
handling and that kind of thing out of
the box so as a consumer I don't need to
uh put that in there it also handles
environment aware authentication so once
again if I'm in development it knows
that I should use my development
credentials and if I'm in production to
use those production credentials and if
I'm on my development uh VM which is
kind of the way that Etsy does a lot of
our development work it knows then to
use that set of credentials we use cloud
run native features for authentication
and authorization so that was another
case we're like using Cloud run we just
didn't have to worry about that
implementation or that uh decision and
it was already it was just an easy
button for our apps SE team to just look
at it's like oh you're using IM we're
good um all services that are running on
the service platform are automatically
registered in our service catalog what
that does is obviously gives us a
catalog hence to name but it also does
some interesting things like we get some
Bas level document mentation like you
get links to the Run books for the
service who owns this what's the on call
schedule what are the links to the
dashboards but we also do things like we
autogenerate like a nice version of API
documentation from the protuff files and
so you can kind of think of the service
catalog page for a service is kind of a
at least an initial hub for a service so
that I as a consumer can go look at that
or if I just need to know more
information I can at least go there and
it links out to other things uh we also
use that same service catalog they we're
um uh integrating that with other
services that are not necessarily in the
service platform so that that can kind
of be the one place stop place because
as you all know if you don't have at
least six documentation repositories
what are you even
doing all the ETC systems like over here
um they use these generated clients to
call out to services so all those great
things I said about the batteries
included there U that's what they do for
example if I'm working in PHP and the
Etsy web monolith which is what we call
the like main Etsy uh product like I
just work with like highle PHP objects
and don't really have to worry about the
uh implementation details I might even
know there's a such thing as a service
platform and I definitely don't even
have to worry about knowing that there's
a thing called Cloud
run just so that you don't think that
we're going to get up here and say all
positive things about Cloud run and
Google Cloud I wanted to at least give
you a couple of uh uh challenges that we
had that we had to work through and some
of these are just obvious in hindsight
as things like this always are but we
wanted to uh highlight them shortly
after we launched this ad
service um we overloaded a VPC connector
for those who don't know uh within
servis to contact with other parts of uh
the Google infrastructure particularly
those things like a kubernetes cluster
or services that run there you go
through this thing called a VP C
connector which sing is going to
completely hate my description of this
I'm sure but basically it's like a proxy
server that's a really bad description
of it uh but it runs on VMS and
everything uh and we just completely
destroyed ours uh uh because we had done
an a huge amount of load
testing and everything looked fine but
it turned out when we actually turned on
this feature in the Etsy website that
user interaction like actual users like
people sitting at their computers and
buying and selling things was completely
unlike what we had modeled before as
users always are so we wind up going
down different paths that hit much
heavier endpoints and so we had to
quickly you know kind of on the Fly go
and make some dedicated VPC connectors
just for these
Services services that we launched after
uh our Pilot service just because we
kind of knew the Pilot service you know
inside and out by that point uh they
were a little trickier for us to
determine what was the best mix of like
CPU and memory all a versus user traffic
versus concurrency particularly with all
the languages that we had involved uh
and since in Cloud run you're running in
um kind of a container and it's you
can't really get a shell you can't
really use like the traditional like
operating system tools that uh we're
used to using like on a virtual machine
so that's where we like heavily
instrumented all of our
applications and we work with the
development teams to do this because
they were the experts at their
applications and everything and then we
took things that made sense we actually
poured those back into the platform so
that everyone would uh have U access to
those it's like everything in a service
platform as I said we use uh uh Google
Im so everything is TLS and uses layer 7
authentication we don't rely on a lot of
like private networks or anything there
but not everything at Etsy does that a
lot of uh older systems at Etsy which
are the money makers
uh we're lifted and shifted from the
data center as Corey said um so we've
actually been working with Google servis
networking team to determine what's the
best way to get a performant but secure
like connectivity from service to
Service as well as service to
infrastructure without exposing a lot of
like low-level details to developers in
our ideal use case and this is still
ongoing we want them to just State I
need this kind of connectivity and this
kind of security and we figured that out
in the service
platform
um um another uh instance that we had
which um like all the Google services
really helped us get started very
quickly uh like particularly the
observability tools because they're just
kind of baked in with Cloud run and they
just work out of the box you just
automatically get uh a ton of metrics
logs and traces however whenever when of
our Engineers gets paged at like 2: a.m.
as you inevitably do or whatever they're
used to working with like grafana and if
they're doing ad hoc things like we're
using promql for things so we actually
did uh a little bit of kind of glue work
with uh Google manag Prometheus and
alert manager so that we could actually
expose all those metrics both the kind
of like Cloud run native ones that come
out of the box as well as all the custom
metrics that we're doing that that we
could expose those into familiar um
interfaces to to our service
developers um another thing uh is um
whenever we first started using Cloud
run sidecar support was I think it was
maybe alpha or even like a private
preview only and so we were not
comfortable necessarily using that uh
and we use open Telemetry for all of our
Telemetry um logging observability and
everything and in general the way that
you do that is run a little agent beside
your code but if you can't run a side
car you wind up accidentally inventing
in a nit system which is what we did and
another thing that we do is we also run
a proxy which is named the entry point
because remember what I said about me in
naming things uh but what it does is
gives us a common place for
functionality regardless of the language
that we're using so one thing that we're
able to do in the entry point for
example is we actually can do
transcoding from like uh Json to
grpc uh so that we can expose things to
like more you know web based endpoints
uh that's also another thing that we
needed to launch so we actually wound up
making this kind of
monstrosity that uh made sure that all
these uh processes were launched and
injected these additional binaries into
the server um containers as we were
working since that time thankfully uh
Cloud run side car support is much
better and uh we've been um working with
that
okay whenever we uh first began working
with the um service platform we focused
more on the day two which is kind of the
care and feeding of uh existing
Services uh because we already had a
very engaged development team in our ads
team and we already had a Pilot service
picked out so we you know really didn't
need to spin up that many services but
since then we've actually done a whole
lot of work to work on that day
one um thing like I have an idea and I
want to tested with ET and so we built a
Sandbox environment in kind of like a a
pair down version of the platform if you
will so I can go from absolutely nothing
type ESP a net which is how you create a
new service and have a sharable link
that something deployed in gcp in about
5 minutes or so so not too bad that
includes cicd and observability as well
um most things have just generally
worked for example after we launched the
ads pilot and we got over our VPC issues
uh they more than quadrupled the amount
of traffic going to this service by
using it in more places around NY which
was great we didn't even really notice
like Cloud run auto scaling just worked
uh not going to say it's always going to
do that but in this particular use case
it worked really well for us
um we have um some requests for things
that do not nicely fit into the uh serus
model and so we're actually working with
Google and our internal gke teams to
actually extend the service platform to
work on uh more traditional gke
platforms as well cuz we want to provide
the same consistent like developer
experience regardless of the runtime and
speaking of that star's going to talk to
us a little bit about how you can use
gke and Cloud run
together thanks Brian that's right I'm
going to tell you how Etsy and all of
you can use both Cloud run and gke
together so first let's recap you heard
it from Drew what's
claudin allows you to deploy and scale
containerized apps in a fully managed
environment so it's simple it's
automated and there's no cluster
management to worry about Google does
that for you and yes Brian we heard you
VPC connectivity could be better so
that's why we've launched a few weeks
ago direct VPC no more sever as VPC
connectors in the middle your cloud
services can just directly send traffic
to your VPC Network
simple and we've also launched recently
sidecars support for cloud run so
notably with sidecars that can help you
bring an observability sidecar like open
Telemetry or PR Google manage
Prometheus check out those two new
features of cloudon I'm a big fan of
them so now
Cloud run and GK many customers have
moved workloads between Cloud run and GK
from and to and actually we've designed
cloudron to avoid lock in and to enable
portability we've designed it that way
from the beginning so obviously the
portability is enabled by cloudon and
gke supporting the same software
deployment artifact the oci container
image the same image can run on gke on
cloud run on your local machine anywhere
containers are running there is nothing
proprietary about Cloud run in a
container that you deploy to Cloud
run but we didn't stop here claron goes
further than that claron is not using
kubernetes under the hood but its V1 API
is designed to enable portability
with
kubernetes and so the cloud on API
actually share the same structures and
attribute as kubernetes so in this
simple example you can see the
similarities between a kubernetes
deployment and a cloud run Service as
you see most Fields look exactly the
same and the diff is just a few
lines so now I'm going to tell you about
how you can use both together in three
ways how you can manage them together
how you can secure them together and how
you can bring them together in the same
data
path so on the consistent management
side first uh there is a product that is
called Cloud deploy Cloud deploy will
allow you to do continuous deployment to
both Cloud run and gke managing
environments and parallel deployments
Canary deployments CL Cloud deploy does
all
that next if that's your thing you can
manage Cloud run services using Cube
control to do that you would need to
leverage something called called config
connector but you can use Cube control
to manage Cloud run if that's what you
want
to then when it comes to buil-in
observability those who run times have
buil-in support for logs into Cloud
logging you can brow browse your logs
from cloudon NG GK in the same place you
can observe the metrics from cloudon or
gke in the same Cloud monitoring
dashboards and you can even Define
service level objectives slos on your
Cloud run services or your gke services
and see them in a centralized location
with SLO
monitoring and finally you can as we
mentioned enforce policies or collect
Telemetry using the exact same side cars
on cloud run and on GK
so that's about management what about
security yes sorry so both claron and GK
have the notion of workload
identity a workload identity is
basically an identity you give to your
services and that determines what it is
able to do and you can use that for the
least privileged security
design
you
can check containers
for vulnerabilities both cloudon and gka
will scan your containers and surface
those vulnerabilities in context of
those
products you can enforce a central
binary authorization policy to decide if
container images should or shouldn't be
deployed to either Cloud r or gke
depending on things like have they been
scanned who has tested that
image and finally you can put all that
within the same VPC service control
parameter when it comes to
networking with a global or a regional
application load balancer you can serve
some endpoints on cloud run and some
endpoints on gke from your users
perspective they are they're coding the
same domain it's the same thing except
that some requests will go to Cloud run
some will go to gke and actually that's
how you can move between Cloud run and
gke invisibly from your end users you
can from one day start shifting traffic
from GK to Cloud run from cloud run to
GK even gradually thanks to application
load
balancers as I mentioned you can
directly connect cloudon services in
your clusters
VPC and uh you can even give private IPS
to cloud services by using an internal
load
balancer so that's how you can use
claudon and GK together but now a
question that you might have is for a
given workload for a given service what
runtime should I
pick and you know what we like to say is
if a workload is a fit for cloud run
which means that it is an autoscale
service or a batch job we like to
recommend starting with Cloud run and if
it's not a fit pick
gke as a mentioned you can always go
back and forth easily later if you need
to so we like to think that claing is
the best way to get going with
containers and that we've enabled using
claudon and gke together that wraps up
our talk thank you very
much we will be taking some live
questions if you want to uh at the mic
right here or you can catch up at the
end uh we are will'll be around and
pleas these
[Applause]
[Music]
are